if jockeying for power
annoys you rather than amuses you
why are you paying so much attention to
politics go watch baseball
I don't know although baseball can be
very intense too go I don't know go to
an art gallery if this if watching
ambitious men jockey to gain power and
attack one another in the process drives
you crazy and makes your blood boil then
stop stop being involved in politics
you're not going to like it that's all
politics is we like to think that those
men once they attain power will govern
in a just way for the common good and do
all these higher-minded things but the
actual process of attaining power is
this this is it this is all that it is